[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight holy smokes was that
intense
so what did we learn last night at the
debate
well america deserves better that's the
first and most obvious thing we learned
all kinds of people said that today and
they were right
this is a great country the most decent
people in the world live here we ought
to be proud of the fact that we're
americans
proud of our culture proud of our
history most of us want it all to
continue
we want the nation our grandchildren
inherit to be as stable and as happy as
the country we grew up in
but last night's debate gave us a little
confidence that will happen it was a
painful highly depressing 90 minutes at
times
things seemed out of control we could go
on about it but you saw it so you know
what it was like that's the overview
but as a political matter the main thing
we learned last night is that it was a
mistake
to spend so much time focusing on joe
biden's mental decline
yes it's real yes joe biden is fading
we've showed you dozens examples of it
for months now but on stage last night
biden did not seem senile
if you tuned in expecting him to forget
his own name and honestly we did expect
that
you may have been surprised by how
precise some of his answers were not all
of them
but enough of them trump isn't going to
win this race by calling joe biden's
senile
nor by the way is joe biden going to win
this race by calling donald trump
a racist as he repeatedly did last night
that slander didn't work four years ago
it will not work now
because personal attacks rarely work
they rarely determine
election outcomes that's obvious if you
look at the results
but it's easy to forget it and many did
what matters
always to voters anyway is what you do
not what you say right now many would
like to see someone defend the country
america has never been under fiercer
attack than it is now virtually all of
the attackers come from the domestic
left
they're democrats they are biden voters
i am the democratic party
joe biden reminded us last night that's
true
it should be enough to keep trump in
office the democratic party has become
more radical than any major party in the
history of the country
its leaders plan to dismantle our system
the system our founders created
centuries ago
a system that countless other countries
have envied so much they copied
democrats want to do away with it they
want to abolish the electoral college
they're trying to end traditional
election day voting they intend to
invalidate the filibuster and guarantee
permanent control of the house and the
senate by admitting dc
and puerto rico into the union we'll
have 52 states
and the democrats will be in charge
forever that is their plan we're not
making it up they've said it
scariest of all they're planning to
hijack the supreme court
by expanding the number of justices
leading democrats have openly endorsed
this idea it's not a small change it
would end our third branch of government
the judiciary would cease dispensing
justice it would instead
become an instrument of partisan power
politics wielded exclusively on behalf
of one party
how'd you like to live in a country like
that it's horrifying
joe biden was asked about this last
night here's how it went
are you willing to tell the american
people tonight whether or not you will
support
either ending the filibuster or packing
the court whatever position i take in
that that'll become the issue the issue
is the american people should speak
you should go out and vote you're in
voting now
vote and let your senators know how
strong will you feel
let vote now make sure you in fact
let people know he doesn't we're
senators i'm not going to answer the
question
because the
so there are a couple of things to note
about the exchange you just saw
nobody forced biden to answer the
question a key question that was
frustrating to watch
but it was also easy to interpret what
he meant of course joe biden plans to
pack the supreme court
otherwise he would have denied it court
packing is not popular with the with the
public
nearly 70 percent of americans oppose it
that includes more than half
of all registered democrats but the
extremists who now run the democratic
party are demanding it
and joe biden will follow their lead
that's what radicalism looks like
anything that stands between you and the
power you seek
you destroy even as if it's the world's
oldest constitutional court
which our supreme court is we should be
afraid of people who are willing to do
things like that
but in joe biden's case we don't seem to
be afraid and that leads to something
else that we learned last night at the
debate
tone is everything biden all but
admitted on stage that he plans to tear
down our system
but he did it in a calm this is your
captain speaking voice
biden seemed almost reassuring even as
he hinted at revolution
donald trump by contrast defended our
system the system that most people in
this country support
nothing trump said on stage was radical
virtually nothing he ever says is
radically at least if you compare it to
public opinion polling on the issues
it's his tone that rattles people trump
could make a wine list sound menacing
and so in the end amazingly tragically
many people watching last night may have
concluded that joe biden
is the stable steady alternative they
concluded this
even as joe biden suggested that he
plans to change their lives their
country
permanently and forever in ways they
won't like
it's quite a trick the illusion of
reasonableness
barack obama was the master of this
biden learned well
and so he continued last night watch joe
biden explain that actually
he's the america first candidate it
would create
an additional one trillion dollars in
economic growth because it would be
about
buying american that we have to we're
going to make this federal government
spend 600 billion
a year on everything from ships to steel
to buildings and the like and under my
proposal
we're going to make sure that every
penny of that has to be made
by a company respectfully
we've got to buy american buy american
says the man who welcomed china into the
world trade organization and has been
sucking up assiduously to its leaders
ever since
fight the billionaire says the man whose
campaign is funded by oligarchs on wall
street and in silicon valley
joe biden stole donald trump's lines
it was remarkable how was biden able to
do that
well the trump campaign should ruminate
on that question
trump's advisers slash in-laws are
telling him to brag about the number of
people he has let out of prison
this at a time when our crime rate is
exploding and people are dying as a
result of it
joe biden's advisers plan to let many
more people out of prison but they're
not bragging about it on stage
no they're hiding it instead they use
the debate to talk up a
buy america program they will never
implement
what we learn here is the biden people
are very serious about politics
they know what the public wants even if
they plan to ignore it
if they're elected and of course they're
willing to say anything
that helps that's another thing we
learned last night we learned that
white supremacy is now the single
greatest threat to our country
how can that be you ask well it turns
out that mobs of white supremacists just
burned down minneapolis and then kenosha
they trashed portland and seattle they
shot cops in louisville they torched
wendy's
they cleaned up the nike store they
destroyed public monuments in atlanta
and san francisco they defaced war
memorials in washington
they looted macy's in midtown chicago
also in the city of chicago white
supremacists murdered hundreds of
african americans
and everywhere they went these
right-wing bigots spray-painted racist
graffiti on buildings
and threatened sleeping citizens in
their homes the white supremacists did
this
you saw it all on tv damn those proud
boys
it was bewildering to listen to all of
this
it wasn't just factually untrue no it
was insane
it was crazier than any conspiracy that
google has ever banned
yet they're now demanding that you
believe it and if you don't believe it
they're going to punish you so why are
they doing that
that's a good question it's also an
ominous sign
if they can make you accept a lie that
ridiculous
what do they plan to do next maybe
someone will ask that question in the
next debate